let's talk about the protests in Lebanon
people have been demonstrating for
months saying they're tired of
corruption and a never-ending economic
crisis for the stop of crushing
liberties freedoms and economic economic
nightmare in which we are in response
Prime Minister Saad Hariri resigned now
Lebanon has a new government but
protesters are still on the streets
they say their message is clear we
haven't given up and we aren't going
away
so why don't they support the new
government and what is the backstory for
what's going on in Lebanon
[Music]
call it an anti-government movement
uprising or even a revolution what's
going on in Lebanon is something many
people there say they haven't seen
before this is a country with 18
officially recognized religious groups
where people have traditionally
supported the interests of their own
faith or sect but this is a new
generation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
people from across the country took to
the streets the sectarian divide was no
longer there there was no class divide
it was the poor it was the middle class
it was the rich of people who were just
fed up protesters say they're fed up
with a lot of things the economy high
taxes lack of jobs crumbling
infrastructure and they say the biggest
problem is rampant corruption which is
thrived under Lebanon's sectarian
political system we're going to explain
that system in a second
but let's get a sense of just how tough
everyday life is for most Lebanese
people we don't really have access to
proper public services like there's no
24/7 electricity there is no clean
accessible drinking water we have piles
of garbage all over the country sewage
is not treated it goes straight out to
the the ocean so it feels like the state
is absent from daily life in Lebanon
most people agree that mess is caused by
serious mismanagement some say it's
because of corruption but you'll also
hear analysts say that Lebanon never
really recovered from a long and
devastating war
[Music]
we're talking about Lebanon's Civil War
which started in 1975 and went on for 15
years militias from different sects and
political groups fought each other for
dominance and also fought among
themselves then Syria and Israel got
involved and the battles became even
more destructive
at the end of the war Lebanon's main
political groups signed the Taif
agreement to make sure they all got a
slice of political power and that's
really the basis for Lebanon's political
system to date a Maronite Christian gets
the presidency the Prime Minister has to
be a Sunni Muslim and the Speaker of
Parliament is always a Shia Muslim in
Parliament seats are shared 5050 between
Muslims and Christians but in reality
there are two big political alliances
which include parties from different
sects and they each have rival foreign
powers backing them March 14 was former
prime minister Saud Hariri's bloc which
has the support of Saudi Arabia and the
US March 8 is the block that includes
the Maronite Christian president
Michelle Owens party and Hezbollah it
has Syria and Iran support so because of
all of those overlapping and competing
interests many people will tell you that
Lebanon's sectarian political system
isn't really sectarian what's really
happening in Lebanon is that there are
political parties that used to be
militias sects are not fighting in
Lebanon it's really opposing warlords
backed by opposing foreign powers and
this is how many say corruption has
gotten so out of hand
many of those powerful political leaders
or the suami as they're called in
Lebanon are said to have focused on
their own political and financial gains
and made themselves very rich
Lebanon has 220 kilometres of coast 180
kilometers of the coast has been
privatized it's now under the control of
either former officials and people who
are close to them I'll just give you one
example a part meters in Beirut the
revenues we're not going to the state
they were going to a private company
controlled owned by people who are close
to politicians now that's not to say
that everyone in Lebanon wants to
overhaul the entire system the majority
still support the mainly sectarian
political parties for a number of
reasons one ideological - they benefit
from those in power we're talking about
at least 100,000 people employed by the
public sector now with their families
could you imagine that numbers Lebanon's
elite has responded to calls for a clean
up and 2019 Prime Minister Saad Hariri
stepped down and after months of talks
the new prime minister
Hassan Diab who's a computer engineering
professor finally announced his new
government according to diab it's made
up of technocrats with no political
loyalties and it even has a record
number of female ministers but not
everyone is convinced this is real
change
so the protesters had demanded for a
completely independent technocratic
government which just means they're
politically independent and also that
they are experts in their fields it's
kind of just the same thing like
different faces but same parties same
alliances critics of the new government
are saying that many of those
technocrats have the support of the
March 8 Alliance the one that includes
Hezbollah and that complicates things
[Applause]
Hezbollah is a Shia Muslim political
group and arguably Lebanon's most
powerful player it has a military wing
the size of a small army funded by Iran
Hezbollah is considered a terrorist
organization by the US and the EU has
blacklisted its armed wing even just the
perception of Hezbollah pulling the
strings might make it hard for Lebanon's
new government to get the international
funding it desperately needs this is a
country with the world's third highest
level of debt when he compared it to its
small economy its debt as more than 80
billion dollars
Lebanon's former Finance Minister
recently told Reuters news agency that
the country will need at least a twenty
billion dollar bailout possibly from the
IMF World Bank and Gulf countries in
2018 international donors agreed to give
Lebanon 11 billion dollars and loans
grants and donations but Lebanon hasn't
seen that money yet the message that
Beirut is getting is enough is enough
you need to undertake painful but
necessary reforms in order for this
funding to be released people in Lebanon
are already feeling the crisis getting
worse since protests began the value of
Lebanon's currency has fallen by 60% and
banks are already limiting cash
withdrawals to about $200 a week
violence is also escalating as police
try to contain the rage
[Music]
so there's defiance and some hope among
protesters that their campaign will lead
somewhere but other Lebanese people we
spoke to say there's still a very long
road ahead one of our lebanese
colleagues despaired that war-torn syria
might be back on its feet before things
get better in lebanon
start here is the Al Jazeera show that
explains what's going on in the news we
have new episodes coming out every week
so make sure to subscribe like and
follow Al Jazeera's social media pages
so you don't miss our next show I'll see
you next week
[Music]